the European market is unfortunately a
fragmented Market in the domain of
digital Healthcare
it's a big issue so if we compare it
with the North American Market or the
Asiatic Market where it's much more
organized
the European companies face quite big
challenges of trying to move and to be
able to operate at the European level
so what is happening at the commission
trying to assist the member states in
the mobility of the European patients
across Europe they have started since
many years now some policies in the
domain to try to harmonize the way we
collect Healthcare data to try to
harmonize them to structure them in such
a way that we can exchange them between
member states the European health data
space creates new opportunities for the
European companies in the domain on one
hand to be able to sell new products
across borders which is not really the
case now
and on the second hand to be able to
collaborate with other companies to
create new products together that at the
European level could create new services
for the European citizens